wir gehen jetzt live rein in den
deutschen bundestag unten rechts sind
sie den bundesgesundheitsminister oben
rechts wolfgang kubicki fdp mann
bundestags vize präsident wird ganz klar
gegen die impfpflicht weiteres kollegen
sorge sehr aufmerksam zugehört habe ist
mir klar geworden dass die teams hatte
wirklich einen sinn hat denn die union
zurück noch eine orientierung und wir
sind dabei irgendwann stellt
liebe kollegen meinen persönlichen bei
persönlichen freemium days waren die
tage meiner corona impfungen ich habe
mich bewusst für die impfung und für
fußball entschieden weil ich der festen
überzeugung war und bin dass es mich mit
großer wahrscheinlichkeit für einen
schweren krankheitsverlauf und vor dem
tod durch corona bewahrt es war für mich
persönlich ein enorm befreiendes gefühl
es ist ein großes geschenk dass dieser
impfstoff innerhalb so kurzer zeit
entwickelt wurde und dass ich mich
außerdem frei entscheiden konnte diesen
schritt zu gehen ich bin froh und
dankbar in einem gemeinwesen leben zu
können indem das möglich ist werden
wir heute über die impfpflicht müssen
wir gleichzeitig darüber sprechen wie
der staat diejenigen gegenübertritt die
sich bisher gegen eine impfung
entschieden ich habe ausdrücklich daran
dass es noch nicht allzu lange her ist
das ist der ausdrückliche wille der über
richtige mehrheit dieses hauses war den
bürgern und bürgern selbst die freiheit
zur entscheidung zu überlassen der
gedanke war grundlegend dass der
staatliche eingriff ab einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt enden muss wenn alle ein
hilfsangebot erhalten haben und dann
jeder das individuelle lebensrisiko
wieder selbst trägt
setzt die mehrheit des hohen hauses nun
aber trotz aller anderslautenden
beteuerungen zuvor die allgemeine
impfpflicht um hat das auswirkungen auf
das menschenbild dass dieses gemeinwesen
aussendet so mag der tag der impfung für
all jene die sich freiwillig hier zu
entscheiden der freedom day gewesen sein
wir werden ihnen nicht nennen an dem sie
gegen ihren erklärten bilden geimpft
wurden
die übrigen kollegen ist es häufig zu
hören dass eine impfung
vernünftig ist und deshalb die
staatliche verpflichtung ein gebot der
gesellschaftlichen notwendigkeit sah ich
teile ausdrücklich die auffassung dass
eine impfung vernünftig ist trotzdem
halte ich die idee der staat liege für
alle bürger nur bürgerfest was
vernünftig ist zumindest für
problematisch
die wellen gründe die wellen gründe sich
nicht impfen zu lassen können vielfältig
sein wir machen es uns viel zu einfach
wenn wir erklären hauptsächlich coroner
leugne und rechtsradikale entschieden
sich gegen die impfung das ist
mitnichten so wir müssen respektieren
dass es durchaus bedenkliche werte
psychologische oder religiöse gründe
gibt eine impfung für sich persönlich
abzulehnen wäre wären wir wenn wir diese
gründe im sinne des allgemein schutzes
als nicht so wieder sicher achten würden
insbesondere
dass wir mittlerweile wissen dass der
fremdschutz durch eine impfung kaum mehr
gegeben ist auch deshalb fällt es mir
schwer bei der impfung von einem akt der
solidarität zu sprechen wie es viele tun
weil impfung keine sterile immunität
liefert die zuallererst im selbstschutz
wir tun gut daran die impfung nicht
durch eine moralische aufladung sondern
solche tatsächlich zu machen denn damit
würden wir sie zwangsläufig politisieren
und menschen die persönliche gründe
geben kann touren können stigmatisieren
und zu karies der gesellschaft machen
die kollegen im kern geht es heute
deshalb auch um den minderheitenschutz
der durch eine impfpflicht gerührt wird
ich möchte jedenfalls nicht dass die
mehrheit für die minderheit festlegt was
man als vernünftig anzusehen hat und was
man nach mehrheitsmeinung tun muss um
solidarisch zu sein denn wenn die
minderheit von der mehrheit im
grundrechtssensiblen fragen und der
rückgriff aber eine höhere moral einfach
überstimmt wird dann können wir nur
hoffen dass wir ihnen die verlegenheit
kommen werden teil einer minderheit zu
sein
liebe kollegen es gibt gute gründe für
die impfung die für eine impfpflicht
überzeugen mich nicht weder droht ein
kollaps des gesundheitssystems
bei massiv steigende infektionszahlen
sinken die behandlungszahlen auf den
sieg stationen noch kann eine
impfpflicht noch etwas zur bewältigung
der mikrowelle beitragen einen massiven
grundrechtseingriff mit einer möglichen
gut ab dem herbst zu begründen die wir
noch nicht kennen und an den impfstoff
den wir noch nicht haben sozusagen eine
impfpflicht auf vorrat halte ich auch
aus rechtlicher sicht für nicht
vertretbar
ich glaube dass aufgemerkt
sonst hätte ich sie auch tadel müssen
ich hätte das auch hingenommen übrigens
auch für sie gilt das zeichen präsident
wenn das auch leicht getrübt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nächster redner ist der abgeordnete
matthias birkwald
aus der fraktion die linke im moment
gerade mehr kubicki was hat er getan er
hat seine moment mal moment mal seine
maske vergessen airlines genau zurück
zum platz wollte dass ich fast den tadel
eingefangen davon der
bundestagspräsidentin von bärbel bas
aber das war schon eine interessante
rede von wolfgang kubicki also noch mal
ganz kurz für unsere zuschauer er
organisiert den widerstand gegen die
pflicht dort im bundestag er hat den
antrag eingebracht in den bundestag
gegen die einführung einer allgemeinen
impfpflicht schon interessant dass er
von dem freedom day gerade gesprochen
hat und hat dann gesagt wie wird sich
dieser tag anfühlen wie werden wir ihn
nennen der tag an dem menschen gegen
ihren erklärten willen sich impfen
lassen müssen also sehr sehr
nachdenkliche ton gerade in dieser rede
von wolfgang kubicki bei uns ist jan
schäfer unser politikchef hast du das
gerade empfunden wolfgang kubicki ganz
klar gegen eine impfpflicht jetzt aber
auch sehr ruhige töne fast schon er kann
ja auch ganz anders angeschlagen also
ich war überrascht in der tat wie ruhig
wolfgang kubicki und wie muss man sagen
eigentlich stromlinienförmig er seine
rede vorgetragen hat war eine kurze rede
er hatte entscheidend begründet aus
seiner sicht warum eine impfpflicht
nicht das richtige ist der punkt freedom
day für diejenigen die sich haben impfen
lassen freiwillig das genau das beispiel
hat er gebracht und ich glaube er hat
auf einen ganz klaren punkt damit auch
hingewiesen wie eigentlich will der
staat die impfpflicht denn durchsetzen
also wenn man keinen zwang auf der
anderen seite aus möchte ungeimpfte
nicht transportieren möchte zu einem
arzt zu einer spritze auch in gewisser
weise bußgelder natürlich für richtig
empfindet aber gefängnisstrafen dann
auch wieder ablehnt dann kommt der staat
natürlich
als jemand der am ende auch recht immer
durchsetzen muss in eine große
legitimierung falle das ein echtes
problem und deswegen glaube ich wird die
impfpflicht nicht dazu führen wie es
einige sagen dass sie die ganze
situation hier in deutschland befriedet
sondern sie wird eher noch zusätzlich
brandbeschleuniger sein und die stimmung
die wir ohnehin schon auf der straße
haben die zum teil in gewalt umschlägt
in mord aufrufe er noch anheizen